a wall to divide the Caribbean island of
Espanola it's designed to separate the
Dominican Republic from Haiti Dominican
General Rafael Nunez says the war will
play a crucial role in protecting his
country against Contraband and illegal
immigration over there you can see where
the first stage ends that involved this
part of the country of the perimeter
wall that we are building Haiti's in
turmoil and thousands are desperate to
escape gang-related violence and hunger
the Dominican Republic is trying to
prevent refugees from entering the
country and has deported over 50 000
Haitians in the past five months General
Frank Cabrera says the Dominican
government is simply not equipped to
offer Refuge to so many needy people
we share a border with one of the
poorest countries in the Western
Hemisphere Haiti is in the middle of a
political economic and social crisis
some say that 60 is controlled by armed
non-state actors or gangs imagine a
country that is controlled by gangs we
allow Haitians to cross and get supplies
but cannot do much more
and that's why for many this wall is
necessary this is what the fence is
going to look like it's going to be
about four meters tall and in some areas
where there's like more population it's
going to have metal bars and in rural
areas it's going to look much more like
this type because the risks of people
trying to cross over are smaller the
wall is being built mostly by Haitian
workers here in the country legally who
represent some of the Dominican
Republic's cheap labor force the wall is
expected to cover 164 kilometers of the
almost 400 that divide both countries
but in Haiti people say it won't stop
them from crossing over and over again
we're here living on an island and
they're trying to stop migrants from
Crossing but you can't really stop this
phenomenon it's going to happen even if
they deport people this will continue to
happen there has to be a change here in
Haiti this is what's needed
promoting stability in Haiti is a stated
priority for countries in the region but
so far most attempts have failed human
rights groups say the wall is a
misguided use of resources that will
further militarize the area and only
push people to take greater risks to
escape
the havon at the Haitian Dominican
border